bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 ce soir nous
sommes au salon de l'agriculture je
recevrai en deuxième partie d'émission
10 grenier président délégué en charge
des questions agricoles au sein du
conseil départemental de l'Essonne mais
d'abord on parle des Yvelines avec
Pauline vinocour Lefebvre
[Musique]
bonjour Pauline vinocour Lefebvre
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
vice-présidente du conseil départemental
des Yvelines déléguer à la ruralité
l'agriculture l'alimentation et les
circuits courts alors dans les Yvelines
les terres agricoles représentent 39% de
la surface du territoire ce n'est donc
pas rien même si quand on pense au
département francilien on pense plutôt à
la ville et à l'urbanisation les
Yvelines sont pourtant une malgré tout
une terre agricole un territoire rural
est donc agricole puisque la ruralité
doit la qualité de ses paysages à
l'activité agricole qui les façonne
alors le département des Yvelines c'est
le deuxième département agricole en
Île-de-France derrière la Seine-et-Marne
qu'est-ce qu'on produit dans les
Yvelines quelles sont les produits
locaux les Yvelines sont essentiellement
un département céréaliers donc céréales
et oléoprotéagineux
avec une diversification de plus en plus
importante soit sur des projets de
transformation de céréales en pâte soit
sur de la vente directe de légumineuses
et
également du maraîchage et un peu
d'élevage mais on est quand même pas un
département d'élevage ça représente pour
l'économie du département ça représente
une part importante l'agriculture une
part importante pour l'économie et pour
enfin comment on le disait tout à
l'heure la qualité des paysages en fait
toute la partie
ouest
sud et nord des Yvelines est
complètement façonnée par l'agriculture
les paysages de vallée de Seine par
l'empreinte du maréchal de
l'arboriculture qui sont moins
importantes qu'elles ne l'était
autrefois mais qui serait implante petit
à petit et donc c'est vraiment le
territoire est profondément marqué par
par l'agriculture alors là nous sommes
au salon de l'agriculture c'est chaque
année un moment important pour le monde
agricole et pour vous en tant que
vice-présidente en charge des questions
liées à l'agriculture est-ce que chaque
année c'est la même chose ou il y a des
différences ou comment ça se passe
alors chaque année c'est le même grand
rendez-vous de tous les acteurs du monde
agricole mais selon les années les
préoccupations peuvent varier alors en
fonction de
la situation géopolitique par exemple je
pense notamment à la crise en Ukraine
l'année dernière qui était un grand
sujet d'inquiétude
cette année je sais qu'un des
[Musique]
gros inquiétudes c'est le sort de la
betterave puisque l'Europe vient
d'interdire les dérogations pour les
néonicotinoïdes et ça met en péril la
production betterave et donc toute la
filière qui est hyper importante en
France voilà donc chaque année les
préoccupations changent mais ce qui est
moi ce qui je dirais matrice c'est que
chaque année il y a de grosses sources
d'inquiétude tant l'agriculture
rencontre des obstacles de toutes sortes
et chaque année on a l'impression qu'il
y en a un nouveau alors nous sommes sur
le stand Yvelines Hauts-de-Seine ça fait
depuis quelques années maintenant que
les deux départements partagent un stand
en commun sont très complémentaires d'un
point de vue agricole pourquoi un stand
en commun au salon de l'agriculture à
quoi ça sert c'est toujours dans
l'optique on sait ce projet de fusion
dans les années à venir
a eu un projet de fusion et il y a
toujours des rapprochements entre les
services
départementaux des Yvelines et des
Hauts-de-Seine après pour ce qui est de
la complémentarité entre nos
départements si je schématise à outrance
on produit il consomme alors on consomme
aussi dans les Yvelines mais
nous on a les terres on a le foncier
agricoles et les Hauts-de-Seine mais
comme le Bassin parisien ont les
consommateurs en face donc des pompes
possibles notamment quand on travaille
sur des logiques de circuits courts il
vit notre scène on reste quand même
relativement proche des pompes aussi
entre nos deux départements et des
débouchés possibles pour nos producteurs
de personnes ça fait des ça fait
potentiel
c'est aussi l'occasion pour les
exploitants de montrer à tout le monde
leur produit aussi de discuter pour les
politiques les syndicats c'est aussi
l'occasion de faire le point vous l'avez
dit aussi sur les pro blématiques du
secteur alors cette année le thème du
salon l'année dernière c'était les
retrouvailles après le covid cette année
c'est l'agriculture le vivant au
quotidien qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
ce thème
le vivant l'agriculture nous nourrit
quoi il nous fait vivre je suppose que
c'est ça en tout cas moi c'est comme ça
que je l'interprète après il y a sans
doute pas mal d'interprétations
possibles je pense qu'un éleveur n'aura
sûrement pas le même la même analyse que
moi le vivant c'est aussi les l'élevage
et les animaux qu'on élève c'est
toujours important de rapprocher les
agriculteurs des citoyens c'est je pense
d'autant plus important dans des
campagnes comme les nôtres dans les
Yvelines qui sont de plus en plus
périurbaines ou en tout cas avec de plus
en plus d'habitants qui viennent des
villes dans les campagnes avec une
vision de la campagne qui est pas
toujours
la bonne avec
l'évolution du mode de vie les gens qui
vont
alors soit des exigences d'urbains à la
campagne soit une vision de la campagne
comme un havre de calme de paix et
surtout sans bruit de tracteur sans
sans bruit de coq et surtout surtout
sans hangar agricole ou poulailler à
proximité or on va pas consommer local
si on n'a pas les outils pour produire
local avant de consommer on produit ce
qu'on consomme alors l'agriculture en
tout cas elle est lustre bien le
mille-feuille administratif français
tout en haut il y a l'Union européenne
donc qui s'occupe de la Pâque la
politique agricole commune il y a aussi
l'état qui doit établir maintenant
désormais donc avec la Commission
européenne un plan de stratégie
nationale puis les régions qui gèrent
les fonds européens pour le
développement rural vient ensuite vous
avec le département quels sont les
compétences que vous avez en matière
agricoles pour qu'on prenne un peu mieux
alors en vrai vous n'allez pas
comprendre mieux parce qu'en réalité on
a aucune compétence obligatoire en la
matière mais dans les Yvelines on a la
possibilité de le faire et donc nous
nous en saisissons notamment pour aider
les agriculteurs à porter un certain
nombre d'investissements et les
accompagner face aux catastrophes
climatiques entre autres et sur un
certain nombre de
sujets que nous sommes sur lesquels nous
sommes en train de réfléchir à nouveau
puisqu'on a lancé les assises de
l'alimentation et qu'un des objectifs
c'est de revoir là où c'est nécessaire
notre politique agricole donc pas une
compétence directe mais pourtant il y a
de l'argent investi dans le secteur
agricole le budget 2023 sur l'année
c'est combien à peu près 800000 euros
par an sur l'agriculture donc le
département vous l'avez dit à lancer les
assises de l'alimentation alors l'idée
c'est de tendre à l'autosuffisance
alimentaire alors c'est un très gros
défi ça paraît un peu compliqué comment
est-ce que vous comptez vous y prendre
en tout cas pour tendre à cette
suffisance alors je sais pas si on y
arrivera sur toutes les productions et
surtout les si on arrivera à couvrir
tous les besoins toujours est-il que
dans un premier temps on va réunir les
acteurs du monde agricole les acteurs
des filières de la transformation et
voir quels sont les points de blocage et
quels sont les leviers que nous
pourrions mettre en place qu'est-ce qui
sortie nous coûte ses acides blanches ça
vient d'être lancé donc on n'a pas
commencé à travailler les groupes de
travail ne sont pas réunis donc je
pourrais vous dire ce qu'il en ressort
au mois de mai quand nous les
restituerons et en moins au mois de mai
j'espère qu'il en sortira un certain
nombre de mesures concrètes mais
également des pistes pour l'avenir et
des choses qui est le délai est quand
même assez court donc je pense que tout
ne sera pas abouti d'ici le mois de mai
alors on parle beaucoup cette année vu
le contexte géopolitique de souveraineté
alimentaire alors ne plus dépendre des
autres pour se nourrir c'est un peu la
logique des circuits courts avec le
département est-ce que ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui les circuits courts il y a
une véritable demande on sait alors ça
fonctionne oui et non c'est à dire qu'il
y a eu un véritable engouement pendant
le le covid et le confinement ou les
gens se sont tournés en masse vers les
ventes directes les points de vente
directe aujourd'hui ce que nous disent
beaucoup d'exploitants ou de
transformateurs c'est que le
leur niveau a baissé
et il est plus bas qu'avant le covid ce
qui pose quand même question sur les
changements d'habitudes des
consommateurs qui peut-être veulent
aller au plus près ou au plus rapide ou
peut-être y a-t-il aussi une question de
coût de ces produits donc tous ces
sujets là vont aussi être discutés au
cours de nos assises de l'alimentation
pour voir quels sont les points de
blocage quels sont les leviers possibles
est-ce que les produits locaux sont pas
assez faciles accessibles sont pas assez
regroupés sont pas assez identifiés
voilà ce sont ces questions là dont on
va aussi discuter pour voir comment on
peut aider ces produits à être plus
visibles et plus consommés
court il faut que ce soit rentable pour
lui il faut pas marcher soit assez
important je pense que c'est toujours
rentable pour l'agriculteur quand il
transforme et parce que il valorise son
projet et il le vend plus cher que quand
avec de la céréale on fait du pain avec
du blé ouais en l'occurrence on fait du
pain
on la transforme et on vend le pain plus
cher que que la farine mais maintenant
faut avoir les débouchés et les clients
alors là où le département peut être un
levier c'est que nous une de nos
compétences obligatoires pour le coup
c'est le ce sont les cantines des
collèges et ça peut être un effet levier
pour alors d'abord pour faire adhérer
d'autres types de restauration scolaires
que celles des collèges et
pour offrir des débouchés à nos
agriculteurs mais ça ne suffira pas un
autre défi aussi en ce moment du monde
agricole c'est de renouveler les
générations agriculteurs ça reste un
métier très traditionnel comment on fait
pour donner envie aux jeunes générations
de se lancer dedans
alors ça je ne sais pas j'aurais
tendance à dire que ils vont me
pardonner l'expression un peu triviale
peut-être que la première chose à faire
c'est d'arrêter d'emmerder les
agriculteurs et de leur tirer dessus à
boulets rouges quel que soit les
pratiques et les innovations qui mettent
en place
et puis dire alors dire que c'est un
métier c'est peut-être un peu simpliste
mais c'est un métier technique
innovant avec des connexions avec la
science et la recherche hyper
intéressante
je m'aperçois que ça peut sans doute
plus qu'autre fois
intéressé et toucher des profils
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus divers
peut-être peut-être mais bon après je
fais confiance aux gens du métier pour
pour donner envie de d'exercer leur
métier les lycées
sans doute mais c'est évident qu'il va
falloir qu'il y a un certain nombre de
fermes qui vont devoir être reprises
dans les années à venir
faute de quoi soit elle fermeront soit
elles sont reprises par des grands
groupes
ça peut être ça sera sans doute
d'ailleurs l'enjeu de de salon de
l'agriculture à venir ça reste un métier
d'avenir l'agriculture l'agriculture
pour
il faut c'est indispensable enfin sinon
la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire elle est quand même au cœur
du sujet et ça pour le coup c'est chaque
année au Salon de l'agriculteur c'est
heureusement un sujet récurrent mais
évidemment que c'est un métier d'avenir
on ne saurait sans passer d'abord parce
que il y a l'enjeu de notre souveraineté
alimentaire et ensuite parce que le pays
dans lequel on vit alors pas la Porte de
Versailles mais le pays dans lequel on
vit est façonné par par l'agriculture
c'est à dire qu'on a plus d'élevage on a
plus les paysages qu'on connaît on a
plus de céréales on a plus les plaines
Yves linoises qu'on connaît c'est et en
ça c'est un enjeu d'aménagement du
territoire majeur merci beaucoup Merci à
VOUS Pauline vinocour Lefèvre d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle donc que vous
êtes vice-président du conseil
départemental des Yvelines délégués à
l'alimentation l'agriculture et les
circuits courts
bonjour grille grenier bonjour vous êtes
président délégué à la ruralité
l'agriculture et l'alimentation au sein
du Conseil
un département peu connu pour sa
ruralité mais tout de même l'agriculture
compose 45% du territoire et Sonia avec
plus de 700 exploitations alors
qu'est-ce que l'on produit en Essonne ah
bah de nombreuses choses c'est vrai que
le contrairement aux idées reçues vous
l'avez dit le département de l'Essonne
et rural et la première activité de la
ruralité c'est l'agriculture et donc on
occupe une grande majorité de l'espace
moi je dis toujours que l'agriculture et
la garante des territoires puisque tant
que il y aura des agriculteurs il y aura
de la nature il y aura de la campagne et
donc c'est déjà un terme fort d'être
garant de territoire ensuite on a on a
un certain nombre de d'exploitation
agricoles enfin donc de chefs
d'entreprise d'abord mais aussi de gens
qui sont passionnés par ce qu'ils font
former et puis qui est qui qui donne au
territoire justement toute sa valeur
au niveau au niveau de développement
économique mais aussi de l'environnement
alors donc les productions elles sont
nombreuses c'est d'abord les grandes
cultures mais c'est aussi beaucoup de
culture spécialisées et des filières
peut-être dans une filière qui
reviennent et puis d'autres qui émergent
principalement donc des céréales mais il
y a aussi de la diversification on va en
reparler plus tard l'agriculture doit
aussi se moderniser en Essonne il y a
deux fermes connectées à Boigneville et
à Boutigny sur Essonne alors à quoi
ressemble une ferme connectée et
qu'est-ce qu'on y trouve alors les
fermes connectées la première c'est
historiquement c'est celle c'est celle
de Boigneville donc qui a été qui est
géré par arvalys donc c'est une ferme
gérée avec des fonds de l'État mais
c'est une ferme expérimentale et de
recherche alors de recherche à la fois
sur le végétal mais aussi sur les
méthodes qu'on peut appliquer pour
justement pour faire pousser nos plantes
avec des soit en méthode biologiques
sans méthode de conservation des sols ou
soit en conventionnelle donc c'est un
soutien pour les producteurs pour faire
des choix de variétés mais aussi pour
faire des choix de méthode
où alternatives par rapport au
désherbage par exemple et puis la
deuxième ferme ma boutique alors ce sont
c'est la chambre d'agriculture qui est
plus
ancrée dans sur ce dispositif et ils ont
choisi des jeunes d'agriculteurs très
dynamiques et très à la pointe du
modernisme justement pour développer
tous les outils connectés alors on
travaille beaucoup avec les satellites
on va aller on travaille beaucoup de des
robots alors que ce soit sur Arvalis ou
sur celle de Boutigny bois une ville ou
Boutigny est un très sudaison sont
vraiment des des pépites et puis des
laboratoires pour l'avenir comme quoi en
réalité rime aussi avec modernité et
puis on connaît aussi donc une
augmentation de l'agriculture biologique
on est seul notamment durant les années
avant le covid est-ce que ce
développement de cet agriculture va se
poursuivre dans les années à venir
est-ce que c'est la volonté en tout cas
de l'équipe départementale alors bien
entendu c'est ça fait partie aussi
un petit peu des objectifs qu'on s'était
fixés il est vrai que l'agriculture
biologique l'Essonne a été un des
départements je vous l'avais dit juste
avant covid qui a le plus converti de
Terra agricoles en du conventionnel en
biologique il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une petite comment dire il y a un
petit problème au niveau du pouvoir
d'achat forcément et comme c'est des
produits qui normalement coûte un peu
plus cher
les les marchés que les débouchés
puissent suivre derrière les
consommateurs font des choix alors il se
trouve aussi que l'agriculture qui n'est
pas biologique et vertueuse aussi et de
l'environnement donc
d'accord on a il y a pas l'appellation
agriculture bio mais il y a une
appellation de d'agriculture à haute
valeur environnementale en fait je veux
dire que les agriculteurs s'adaptent
aussi à ce que le consommateur veut le
consommateur veut quelque chose de sain
et quelque chose de proche donc là aussi
forcément alors ça en réalité ça peut
mettre en concurrence les producteurs
sur place mais on est là justement nous
aussi pour essayer de de d'harmoniser
toutes ces filières alors la grande
spécialité en Essonne c'est le cresson
la département en produits près de 40 %
de la production nationale comment
est-ce que l'on peut faire pour le
valoriser au maximum ce produit made in
Essonne alors donc oui le cresson
estonien et mondialement connu puisque
on a des producteurs qui vendent même en
Angleterre et donc et le 6 décembre la
région de mai de Méréville fallait
vallées de la Juine les vallées de
l'école
sont vraiment là où il y a le plus de
créciculteurs de de en France en France
et et justement on est en train de
travailler avec le local les
intercolocal le PNR du Gâtinais et le
département a créé une
IGP du cresson alors GP création de
Méréville mais qui bénéficiera toute la
filière et puis au niveau Île-de-France
il y a aussi cette marque qui a été
lancée par le Conseil Régional produit
en Île-de-France ça aide aussi les
produits et Sonia
on fait tous partie de cette même
dynamique et si vous voulez c'est un peu
les poupées russes donc le local qui
s'inscrit dans le départemental puis
dans le régional et donc
on a la chance aussi en Île-de-France
d'avoir
ce bassin de consommateur très justement
offre énormément de débouchés 13
millions de consommateurs rapportés de
la main dans tes régions ne peuvent pas
n'ont pas cette chance cette chance là
et donc à nous de trouver les bonnes les
bonnes passerelles justement pour que on
valorise à la fois des métiers des
produits et tout un territoire alors la
diversification agricole aussi c'est
important pour les agriculteurs et pour
les territoires quatre agriculteurs et
soignants avec deux collègues yvelinois
souhaitent relancer la filière viticole
en Île-de-France un renouveau car la
filière existait déjà il y a des siècles
mais elle s'était arrêtée les premières
dégustations pourraient arriver au
printemps vous encouragez vous cette
initiative j'imagine bien sûr bien sûr
on a un groupe d'agriculteurs justement
sud et Sonia et Sud divinois qui se sont
regroupés en CUMA pour essayer de
relancer cette filière alors c'est la
filière viticole c'est plusieurs métiers
on fait aussi on fait du raisin et puis
après il faut faire le vin donc
ça redemande un vrai remplissage mais
donc souvent ce sont des jeunes qui qui
se lancent mais avec avec l'aide de
leurs parents parce que ça demande
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre aussi en tout
cas c'est plutôt voilà une filière
ancestrale qui revient sur le territoire
donc
comme le chanvre l'était aussi c'était
une filière ancestrale qui arrive à à
surgir sur le territoire donc c'est
plutôt de bonne augure bien entendu le
département est là pour accompagner ces
nouvelles filières pour essayer de
la région fait beaucoup le département
vient en complément pour l'équipement de
matériel spécifique pour essayer aussi
aider à la formation donc voilà donc ça
fait partie aussi de nos labels alors
justement pour y comprendre un petit peu
sur qui fait quoi entre la Région le
Département l'état l'agriculture donc
c'est la compétence des régions
principalement avec les européen pour le
développement de l'agriculture et de le
développement rural le font fédère vous
au département est-ce que avec la
rivière la région vous pouvez disposer
un peu de ses fonds quels sont vos
compétences finalement en matière
d'agriculture alors en fait oui on se
cale beaucoup sur ce que la région fait
dans ces politiques de agricoles et on
essaye d'être soit complémentaire soit
en interface pour accompagner les
développements des filières mais aussi
le développement des méthodes donc
l'alternative par exemple aux produits
chimiques des herbages chimiques et bien
on aide aussi à l'acquisition de
matériel de désherbage mécaniques ça va
être dans l'aide à l'investissement
dans l'aide par exemple il y a une
urgence il y a une crise ça c'est plus
secteur alors nous département on n'a
pas le droit de faire du développement
économique donc on agit surtout sur le
secteur
aménagement local donc nos agriculteurs
sont des aménageurs du territoire donc
par ce biais là on peut les aider mais
on a aussi pour revenir au fond au fonds
européens on accompagne aussi des
programmes leaders que le certaines
territoire ont réussi à développer je
pense notamment au Plateau de Saclay ou
au PNR du Gâtinais ou là le département
de l'Essonne abonde les fonds puisqu'il
faut un cofinancement local et donc dans
sa politique agricole il y a des fonds
sont dédiés pour accompagner les projets
des porteurs de projets dans le
développement des filières la
diversification l'aide à la vente
directe par exemple alors les circuits
courts ont aussi le vent en poupe ces
derniers ces dernières années c'est un
peu la nouvelle mode en matière de
consommation et il y a ce projet donc au
département de l'Essonne de légumerie
départementale l'objectif
approvisionner les cantines scolaires
notamment des collèges du département
et des sept EHPAD départementaux en
produits frais et bio alors on tablette
sur une nouvelle turf en 2023 parce que
c'est toujours le cas où le projet va on
a un petit peu plus de retard 2023 ça va
être la concrétisation de notre projet
de légumerie départementale
bon je pense pas que on y verra plus
clair en 2024 on est encore en phase
d'élaboration par contre on s'est
aperçoit aussi que ce serait c'est
dommage de faire une structure que pour
nos collèges donc on ouvre le champ
aussi aux autres collectivités qui ont
des restaurations collectives à
notamment
on est en train de créer la structure
juridique qui va encadrer la légumerie
et on se on on
s'oriente vers une SPL une société
publique locale dans laquelle les
collectivités seront aussi actionnaires
donc ça sécurisera un petit peu
l'ensemble aussi et puis aussi il faut
qu'on se partenariat avec les
producteurs il faut aussi qu'on se
sécurise à ce niveau là et donc là il y
a un gros travail de fait avec la
Chambre d'Agriculture pour que par
exemple d'insérer allié en boîte le pas
sur du légume de plein champ pour
pouvoir approvisionner la légumerie
alors or on parlait tout à l'heure de
diversification
alimentaire on est seul on produit
principalement des céréales encore
encore peu de culture maraîchères il va
falloir les développer si on veut
justement approvisionner ces cantines
scolaires comment ça va se passer du
coup du coup l'état vous avez le monde
agricole c'est s'adapter rapidement on
va avoir de plus en plus de faire
maraîchers dans les prochaines années je
pense que les maraîchers qui sont déjà
sur le circuit ont déjà une clientèle ou
un marché de plein vent ou en AMAP donc
je pense que ça les intéresse pas
forcément
d'alimenter une légumerie on va se je
pense avoir le plus de légumes qui
viendront une diversification de légumes
de plein champ donc ça sécurise aussi
les quantités malgré tout voilà ça peut
ça va aussi élargir le champ du possible
au niveau de la diversification des
produits puisque on va aussi aller sur
du légume sec ou il y en a il y a pas
beaucoup de légumes secs en Essonne sur
des alors c'est pareil il faut aussi que
le monter en charge progressive de tout
ça au départ on va on aura des
fournitures de légumes très basiques
mais le panier va s'élargir au fil de au
fil du temps et puis avec aussi une
volonté de derrière répondre à la
saisonnalité puisque
bizarrement les
tomates par exemple elles arrivent à
maturité quand les écoles sont fermées
donc il faut trouver le bon système
aussi donc on réfléchit à
ultérieurement faire une mise à la
chaîne du froid et puis la surgélation
et pourquoi pas une conserverie mais on
se fera ce projet merci beaucoup je vous
en prie d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes président délégué
à la ruralité et à l'agriculture au sein
du conseil départemental de l'Essonne et
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de lève de
politique sur Radio sensation et sur TV
78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]